[Music]
[Music]
hey you're sorry you're live on the
podcast who is this now sam
oh wow he called me but i think he knows
that we're doing the podcast so i wanted
to
i was trying to ask if you thought girls
or eye ladies was funnier
why are you doing a women's day post
what no
egirls or eye ladies
yeah
i ladies
i laid these nuts across that face
oh
oh
we haven't heard sam's voice on this
podcast in years
and he
came through with a zinger
[Laughter]
he girls
or if i had joey if i had chosen
would he did he have one for that or did
i just
fall hook line and sinker for that
[Laughter]
you know i was juggling
i was juggling a lot of things
we were in the middle of a conversation
the face time came and get him on the
and then i didn't i wasn't paying
attention
it was right in front of you man
hi ladies hi ladies
ladies
a moment of weakness
that's why your [ __ ] egg face didn't
get casted in that [ __ ]
because it's because of that yeah
exactly that was actually the suit
column yeah yeah yeah yeah
that was actually one of my lines
in the pilot they just wanted to see if
i picked up on it or not yeah and i
didn't yeah i just said it you know can
you imagine it's like cody's not the guy
why i'll prove it to you right now yeah
watch this
hey cody it's sam
yeah yeah hey buddy uh what's better e
girls or eye ladies
i laid i ladies nuts across your face
hold bored ah
i told you
every time sir every time what an idiot
kid's got no foresight god damn it so
anyways this is this is the interview
process for tmg studios yeah
hey man thanks for stopping in today so
just a quick question to get started
e-girls are high ladies
um hi ladies oh my ladies nuts across
your face um better luck next time pal
yeah thanks for coming in i laid this
red carpet out of the building yeah
and then we slam the door and then we
roll up the
uh we we removed the breakaway wall to
the entire staff who was watching that
interview
in studio live or like
it's all about the future
this person cannot see the future